okay let's get right into audience
questions first one today David I've
heard you say that the stock market does
better with Democratic presidents than
Republican does the country always do
better when there is a Democratic
president economically so we have to
know what metrics were looking at when
we try to measure how the country is
doing there are a number of different
indicators that we would look at no one
indicator tells us everything we need to
know we would look at GDP growth
unemployment and stock market
performance certainly as indicators we
would probably take a look at what
portion of the country is poor below the
poverty line what's the degree of
inequality there are other metrics that
can be a little squishier because they
relate to others so we could say well
how strong is the dollar but that would
be related to our a trade deficit or
surplus and it's harder to say we're
doing well or were not without kind of a
more systemic approach and then you've
got intangibles right like how respected
are we around the world right now
respect for the United States is very
very low because of Donald Trump how do
you sort of price that into the equation
but to pick a few of these indicators
yes the stock market does better under
Democratic presidents than Republicans a
lot of people don't care about the stock
market the stock market is not the
economy as we have very clearly seen
during the last three months of
coronavirus but the return the
annualized return during Democratic
administrations has been fourteen point
three percent whereas it has been ten
point eight percent under Republicans so
yes the stock market does better under
Democrats in terms of GDP growth GDP
growth is significantly higher under
Democratic presidents than Republican
presidents typically it depends on
exactly how you measure and and certain
timing issues but it's anywhere from
fifteen to forty four percent larger GDP
growth during Democratic presidential
administrations then republican in terms
of unemployment unemployment tends to be
higher during Republican administrations
eighteen
percent higher by one study that I
looked at in terms of job creation
remember jobs created and the
unemployment rate are two different
things since World War two Democratic
presidents have seen more than a twenty
four point four million more jobs
created during their watch that's an
average of seventy eight percent more
jobs created per year of Democratic
administrations versus Republican
administrations so yeah by those
indicators we do better with Democratic
presidents now the thing is somebody
believes Republicans are just better for
the economy these data won't convince
them they'll say well some of that is
because of lag time you see better
metrics when a Democrat takes over
because of the policies the Republican
put in place this has been pretty widely
debunked but still people continue to
repeat it you will sometimes hear well
Democrats spend in order to make some of
these metrics look better well it's like
if you trust the metrics and government
spending improves the metrics then
that's good right I mean they would the
right will try to argue that these are
sort of like cheap ways to quote improve
the economy which sounds crazy I mean it
literally sounds crazy other metrics
like poverty I mean the thing about
poverty is if I change the poverty level
if I say well instead of being poor at
fifteen thousand dollars a year you're
only poor below twelve I've just taken
millions of people out of poverty I've
not really changed anything so that's
why poverty is not really the the best
metric inequality is important but as
always you know mean median mode looking
at something like the Guinea index GI ni
there's different ways to look at that
but in short yeah I mean the traditional
indicators that we look at suggest that
the economy does better when we have a
Democratic president than a Republican
president since the early 1900's when we
have
you know more or less or really even the
World War 2 era we would say when things
are sort of measured in in the same way
and you can always I mean the reason I'm
sort of hesitating is that this question
is inherently fraught because any
empirical differences you can point to
can be explained away by motivated
reasoning and so it's a fair question
but it's a really difficult one to
convince anybody about in a way that
would materially change their
perspectives on what the right policies
are